déjà très émue et déjà ému ma chérie
parce que fabien du cac c'est pour mes
enfants et ça vient du casse pour tes
enfants tu sais que tu as beaucoup de
difficultés 80e voulait absolument un
instrument demandé un sapin et des
cadeaux oui et c'est vrai que c'est que
vous avez des difficultés vous pouvez
même pas vivre avec du chauffage
non là on en a parlé dans fait très
froid je sais ma chienne je sais vous
avez envie de passer noël avec des
sapins avec des cadeaux oui tu es ma
chérie forcément tu crois vraiment que
j'allais trop fusée ce cadeau j'y ai cru
je croyais en 3 depuis ses manières donc
ma chérie regarde on va ouvrir le rideau
regarde ce cas pour toi
pour les enfants
jo les enfants avec les enfants
venir
koné les enfants
il ya un petit toit
ma chérie bonnet mecheri venez venez van
eeuwen emmanuel moire du capteur machine
mais miley sétois quesnel samedi
chéri d'amour je te fais un gros bisou
au curage et toi comment tu t'appelles
ghislaine 128 go seulement vos gosses
oui chérie alors tout ça c'est pour vous
tous les cadeaux c'est pour vous mais
j'ai une autre surprise fond jaune autre
surprise pour vous parce que votre
message m'a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
touché et je sais que vous avez dû
quitter votre emploi ya pas longtemps
vous est arrivé de guadeloupe il ya deux
ans vous êtes expulsé votre appartement
vous avez vécu dans une chambre d'hôtel
avec vos quatre enfants et votre chien
exactement le petit chien la chambre
était trop cher la mairie vous accorder
un logement du relance et vous vivez
actuellement donc dedans et ça fait
plusieurs années que n'avait pas fêté
noël j'espère que vous aller le fêter
cette année mais noël vous avez votre
famille la wii et vous avez vous avez de
la famille sinon mon frère ou sa infante
nés avant des et sinon votre maman là
elle est où votre maman tu fais quoi tu
loupes en guadeloupe notamment l envoi
de loupe
oui elle un goût de tous je sais que
vous n'avez pas c'est l'argent pour
aller la voir en guadeloupe pas pour
l'instant tous les cas pour l'instant
et bien quand vous n'aviez pas assez
d'argent pour aller en guadeloupe
on a fait venir votre moment et tout
autre analyse sur la
sa maman voilà maman
on vous laisse vous retrouvez les chéris
messier alors à côté nous alors c'est
qui donc ça sera bon mais ça c'est maman
ouais mon frère à votre frère aîné david
et et ma fille elle en fait et ça
faisait combien de temps vous les avez
pas vu mais ça fait plus d'un an plus
d'un an que vous pouvez pas l'ombre et
le bonnet moment venu je vous fasse un
gros business venez là venez là les
chéris venez là n'ont rien demandé
messier mais chérie je voulais essayer
de le trouver